bonjour on est actuellement au siège
parisien de l'unesco à l'occasion de
l'exposition photographique de alexandre
tchin tchin le photographe russe le mot
dans les visages consacré aux peuples
autochtones du monde entier venaient je
vous avais
[Musique]
deluce de sibérie aux tribus éthiopienne
le nez secours met à l'honneur les
peuples autochtones
jusqu'au 31 août 2021 l'organisation des
nations unies dédiée à la culture et à
l'éducation accueille entre les murs de
son qg à paris l'exposition des world in
fine le monde envisage du photographe
alexander ki-moon chine l'occasion pour
l'organisation internationale de
rappeler son engagement à la
préservation des 475 millions
d'indigènes disséminés sur la planète
hockey l'unesco a toujours défendu la
diversité linguistique et le
multilinguisme que ce soit physiquement
ou en ligne en accordance with its
conformément à son engagement à
faciliter la construction de société
plus inclusive et à assurer un accès
universel à l'information
cette exposition a pour but
souligné l'importance de la préservation
de langues des cultures surtout de betty
peuples autochtones
parce que la perte
le
d'une langue c'est une perte pas
seulement pour le pays
wardy de ce peuple mais merci pour le
monde pour la culture universelle
c'est en 2012 qu'alexandre ki-moon chine
entame sa série de portraits d'origine
sibérienne le photographe a parcouru
plus de 40000 km sans interruption
parfois dans des conditions climatiques
extrêmes à la recherche des minorités
ethniques qu'il photographie dans leurs
habits traditionnels mais cet honneur de
la russie que tout a commencé
j'ai parcouru 86 pays du monde je me
suis dit j'ai vécu en russie pendant
tant d'années
j'y suis né pourquoi n'ai-je pas prêté
attention à la russie je voulais combler
ce vide
alors je suis allé en sibérie je viens
moi-même de yakoutie et j'ai démarré ce
projet c'est avec cette histoire
sibérienne que ce projet a commencé à
conquérir le monde
même s'il y avait d'autres peuples c'est
bien cette sélection de photographies
qui a été publiée sur internet est
devenue virale par la suite avec le
soutien de l'unesco
alexander espère déclencher une prise de
conscience de la communauté
internationale concernant la menace
d'extinction qui pèsent sur les peuples
indigènes une menace exacerbée par
l'épidémie de kobe de 19 et le
réchauffement climatique afin de lutter
contre la disparition des traditions et
des 7000 langues indigènes l'onu
organise une table ronde à new york le 9
août prochain à l'occasion de la journée
internationale des peuples autochtones
[Musique]
je me rappelle que vous pouvez visiter
cette exposition jusqu'au 31 août 2021
et moi je vous dis à bientôt pour de
nouvelles rencontres culturelles
[Musique]